mr president thank you so much for
joining us thank you
uh on friday ted wheeler the mayor of
portland sent a letter to you
saying basically we don't want your help
you make matters worse
saturday one of your supporters is
murdered
uh in portland by it looks like a
suspected antifa
individual and then on sunday wheeler
comes out
and biden and essentially tries to blame
shift
to you for the violence there your
reaction
well these are terrible and very
incompetent people portland's been
burning for many years for decades it's
been burning but now it's gotten to a
point they don't want to
i watched the mayor try and get in with
these people
and he went to a protest and he went in
and they almost killed him if he didn't
have security whether he had five
security guards
he would have been dead just like they
would have done to rand paul who's a
great guy and his wife kelly
uh it is a disgrace when you look at
what's happening
now we sent in homeland security the
reason we sent them in was to protect
our courthouse we have a 300 million
dollar courthouse
and they wanted to blow up our
courthouse or burn it down
take your choice blow it up or burn it
down they said and i said no no
that's not happening so they wouldn't
protect it because the mayor said
he doesn't care so we sent in our
homeland people they did a great job
immediately homeland security
immediately it was protected and that's
the only reason they were there
i've offered to send in the national
guard i've offered to send in anybody
they want i could put that out in 45
minutes and it would stop
and i think the people of portland and
the people of oregon
i know it's a liberal state considered
liberal they're tired of it they're
tired of having
of living with this curse they're living
with a curse
they say that when you walk through the
streets of
portland this is years and years of
burning and
it's in the last 90 days it's been
really no it's been
horrible in the last 90 days but no it's
been going on for many it's been going
on for
many many years it's like you're in i
won't name the city but it's a city
someplace in the world that's not
so good okay it's a terrible city the
oregon governor said
no one is safe in donald trump's america
they're trying to turn the tables on you
after months of they're not really
saying much about the violence right but
they won't ever
criticize anybody that truly you know
that that's a violent person frankly
that's violent
they stick up for the violence they
don't the people that are getting hurt
they don't care about they don't care
about these people
it's a weird thing it's like warped
minds
and for the last 93 days i've been
offering to send and as you know they
have to take the offer they have to make
they have to ask to have help i've been
standing and i've been saying
anytime you're ready we'll put it out
what's motivating them mr president i
think it's a sickness
actually i think there also there's a
fear i watched uh the way they treated
this mayor wheeler when he was standing
there
and i'll tell you how unfair the news is
nbc news didn't
show that he was being shouted at and
cursed at
and he ran literally he had a run for
his life because they were going to
really hurt him he had security if he
didn't he would have probably
they showed up as an apartment building
over there no no how he can still stick
up for him i think there's a fear i
think he's afraid
are they afraid that oregon could be in
play because of
people's concern about law enforcement
it could that what you're saying it
could
i don't know i don't know i think that
like the mayor wheeler i think he's
probably afraid for his life because if
you would have seen him but i'll show
you how dishonest nbc news
put on and they didn't have the people
shouting they had him standing there
and they talked about how it was a show
of great unity the mayor standing with
the people
those people were going to kill him they
were saying things that i can't repeat
right now
but horrible things but they didn't put
that on i actually happen to see the
real tape on fox
he escaped with his life and yet
he doesn't want any help it's so unfair
to the people of oregon we could solve
that problem quickly like i did
in kenosha you know kenosha went through
three or four days of you wouldn't have
a kenosha right now
we demanded that they send in the
national guard
called the governor in all fairness the
governor did it not enough
but it was enough to put it out and we
ultimately
put in more we had a thousand people and
we put it out quickly
you wouldn't have kenosha right now um
in
pittsburgh today joe biden gave a speech
and he spoke directly about this
violence
he may believe mouthing the words law
and order makes him strong
but his failure to call on his own
supporters to stop
acting as an armed militia in this
country shows how
weak he is your response to the vice
president sir
look he's a weak person he's been weak
all his life but now he's really weak
uh he shouldn't be running for president
he should not be there but do you want
your supporters to confront
the left-wing protesters or do you want
to leave it to law no i don't want them
i want to leave it to law enforcement
but
my supporters are wonderful hard-working
tremendous people
and they turn on their television set
and they look at a portland or they look
at a kenosha before i got involved and
stopped it
or they look at chicago where 78 people
were shot last weekend
and numerous people died or they look at
new york where violence is up by like
what 150
it's up by a number that nobody and
people are leaving
they're looking at all of this and they
can't believe it
they can't believe it whether it's my
supporter or not but you don't want them
showing no well it's a peaceful protest
i mean they were protesting they weren't
you know it's amazing they want to
protest
and they get criticized the other people
run through the streets burn down
storefronts hurt people
beat people and kill people kick people
in the face that would have happened to
rand paul by the way and his wife
except that you had two and then
ultimately four very good policemen who
took a big beating
they took a big beating and they really
saved rand paul in fact we're going to
bring them into the white house and give
them some kind of an accommodation
because
they really they really that what they
did was
very brave actually i mean can you
imagine i'm saying policemen were brave
because they're escorting
but they're escorting a u.s senator and
his wife
and as rand said he would have been
killed if they weren't there isn't it
true also mr president that democrats
have been in their own way
inciting this violence against
individuals
for as almost as long as you've been in
office
if you see anybody from that cabinet you
get out and you create a crowd
and you push back on them and you tell
them they are not welcome
anymore anywhere please get up in the
face of some congress people there needs
to be unrest in the streets
the domestic enemies to our voting
system and
our honoring our constitution are right
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue
with their allies in the congress of the
united states
it's not only the democrats it's the
media the fake news
the news is so fake like i told you with
the mayor where they make them look like
it's a great unity thing when actually
they were cursing at him and they would
have done big numbers on him but they
don't show that
they just show the mayor standing with
these very tough thugs
and uh he was gone okay
they saved him but nbc shows it like
it's unity with the people
i don't get it i don't know why they're
doing it and i say
i will say this at some point i will not
be president
hopefully that'll be in five years from
now but i will not be president
and they're gonna die they're all gonna
die can you imagine if they had to cover
sleepy joe biden it won't be very
much fun but much more importantly our
country would go to hell our stock
markets will crash as sure as you're
sitting there
we will have problems like you've never
had but if you take kenosha
and if you take other parts of the
country that i don't even talk about
i could show you things that we've done
to stop this kind of a thing that's
happening in portland and happening in
chicago
and happening in other places most red
states are
cooperating with federal law enforcement
and things are relatively calm
in in red state america but biden said
again today in pittsburgh
uh that essentially you you're not going
to be safe
in donald trump's america so uh if it
weren't donald trump's america to just
use the expression as
i'm president uh you would have
riots like you've never seen the the
democrats have lost control of the
radical left
and if you look at bernie and the i call
it the manifesto that was agreed to with
biden and his group
that's further left than bernie ever was
they won't be able to control these
people these people have lot they have
lost control
of these people and it's hurting them
don't forget biden wasn't going to come
out of his basement until the election
now he had to because the polls are so
good for me
now he had to because the polls are
different so all of a sudden he's in
pittsburgh
he wasn't going to leave his basement
then he said okay
he's leaving but he won't leave for ten
days ten days is a long time
so in the meantime like on sunday
and so or saturday i'm in texas i'm in
louisiana
i was going to stop in two other places
fortunately they didn't get hit arkansas
wasn't hit very much et cetera et cetera
i would have stopped
but i'm all over the place i leave early
in the morning i get home late at night
and that's what you have to do as
president and
jon doesn't have energy tomorrow you're
going to kenosha wisconsin of course the
the scene of so much unrest uh lately
and the governor says he doesn't want
you to come
why is it important for you to be seen
by the people of wisconsin now because i
am a tremendous fan of law enforcement
and i want to thank the law enforcement
they've done a good job and when the
governor says that
i shouldn't come or he'd prefer that i
not come i'm the one that called him
and said tony you got to bring out the
national guard well i don't really want
to do it tony you got to bring it out
and unlike your governor of oregon that
just keeps saying no
he agreed to it at least now he agreed
to a small number but the small number
was plenty but isn't it a political
motivation
they don't want you to come to blue
state america
because they don't want the media to
have to cover what's really happening
isn't this politically true if you look
at what's going on there blues as you
call it blue state america blue city
america
you look at what's going on in new york
you look at what's going on in these
states
chicago is a disaster portland you look
at portland
now portland's a little different that's
anarchists and that's
i actually think in many ways that's
easier to handle i think portland is
very easy to handle
because that's a group of anarchists
that are paid by the outside
and you know we put a lot of people in
jail i don't know if you know this or
not
remember uh three four months ago we're
having a problem with monuments they
were ripping down statues and monuments
democrats didn't say anything about that
well the democrats had no control
it actually got out of control even for
them i signed in
an executive order 10 years in jail if
you knock down
a statue or monument you haven't heard
one thing about it
you hadn't we wouldn't have they were
going after thomas jefferson
they were going after lincoln and they
were going after the washington monument
if they could knock that one down
they were going after everything and i
actually don't even think they know i
think they're just
thugs i don't think it's it's it may be
an ideology and it may not
it is an ideology for the people that
are paying them and the funny thing is
and the strange thing is the people that
are paying them and all this money
because somebody's doing it well wait
the people paying them
those people will be overthrown their
lives will be taken away
their lives will be endangered they're
all going to be gone they're just stupid
foolish people that made a lot of money
but corporations have given an enormous
amount of money in the tens of millions
or maybe hundreds of millions to black
lives matter
which is all over a lot of these
protests so what does that mean
about these corporations why are they
paying that money out because they're
weak
people led by weak people in many cases
not all corporations what does that mean
i looked at numbers where one company is
giving hundreds of millions of dollars
when you say they're weak what do you
mean
because they just do what's the easiest
path
that's not the easy pet that's a very
dangerous path black lives matter is a
marxist organization
you remember pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon that was the first time i
ever heard of black lives matter
i said that's a terrible name it's so
discriminatory it's bad for black people
it's bad for everybody
and all of a sudden it becomes like sort
of although now if you look it's going
way down because people
are tired of this stuff what's going on
the black lives matter if you look at
what's going on with the bats and the
a lot of thugs running through dc last
night oh it's terrible what's going on
but black lives matter came into
existence
walking down the street screaming pigs
in a blanket fry them like bacon
and that was about police office that
was representing police
they were pigs pigs in a blanket like
the sausages or hot dogs
fry them like they were saying worse
over the last couple of days oh i think
even worse yeah probably
i don't know do you get worse but doj's
role
in in trying to really hit the law
enforcement uh
accelerator here against these groups a
lot of the individuals coming into
wisconsin
have been tracked as out-of-staters ones
who've been arrested
we have them all can can doj do more and
what could they do
to really start putting the fear of god
in these violent pray not the peaceful
protesters
but violent protesters so they have
under investigation a lot in fact i'll
show you i just had this
because of this very important interview
with you but i just
and i'll give this to you in kansas city
violence has decreased by a third since
the initiative began in indianapolis
49 guns confiscated more than 1 000
arrests have been made under the
initiative
uh doj is addressing violence and crime
across the country fbi but you don't
read that
the fbi and atf are assisting the
portland police department
but you can't do much when you have
absolutely no cooperation but if they
don't think they're going to go to jail
for 10 years
for doing what they're doing then
they're going to keep doing it so how
does a
trump re-election calm things down in
the united states biden says he's going
to calm things
down how will a trump election come why
why won't he calm things down biden
won't calm things down they will take
over
they will have won if biden gets in they
will have one
he's a weak person he's controlled like
a puppet
so it's not going to be calm things down
it's going to be they will have won they
will have taken over your cities
it's a revolution you understand that
it's a revolution
and the people of this country will not
stand for that they're not going to
stand for that
the vast majority of people feel like me
they feel like
every time i put law and order up on
social media it gets
such an incredible positive response
the people of this country will not
stand for it if you say calm things down
yeah
calm things down because they will have
taken over take a look at what's going
on
and biden well biden is i don't even
like to mention biden because he's not
controlling anything
who do you think is calling biden's
strings is it former obama
people that you've never heard of people
that are in the dark shadows
people that what does that mean that
sounds like conspiracy theory dark
shadows
people that you haven't heard of they're
they're people that are
on the streets they're people that are
controlling the streets
we had somebody get on a plane from a
certain city this weekend
and in the plane it was almost
completely loaded with
with thugs wearing these dark uniforms
black uniforms with gear and this and
that they're
they're on a plane where's the words
i'll tell you sometime but
it's under investigation right now but
they came from a
certain city and this person was coming
to the republican national convention
and there were like seven people on the
plane like this person and then a lot of
people were on the plane
to do big damage they were coming
planning for washington yeah this was
all
this is all happening but the money is
coming from somewhere money is coming
from how can it be
from some very stupid rich people that
have no idea that
if their thing ever succeeded which it
won't they will be
thrown to the wolves like you've never
seen before